[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: How might
we live in harmony with nature?
And if you go one
step further-- and I
think I'll put this into context
of all the different things
I've been doing, whether it
is, for example, the advisory
on, like, making a physical
environment zero waste,
you know, like not having an
impact on the environment,
or looking at the data
that we can collect
from smart cities and
sensors and things
like that to
understand how best we
can make those decisions for
future designs, buildings, et
cetera.
One thing that I'm super
interested in at the moment
is the use of new technologies,
like Fourth Industrial
Revolution-type technologies
and understanding
how people like us are
actually using dialogue
to understand how
best we can understand
that technology in the
context of the lives
that we want to live with
the philosophy that we have.
So it's as if that
philosophy was
the basis and the
foundation, and then you're
going to build
everything on top of it.
Another thing that I'm looking
at in a much more practical
level is really looking
at how businesses procure
their products and
their services,
and going into the,
say, supply chains
and understanding at
that supply chain,
where do you get
your products from?
Where are the
resources coming from?
And is there an alternative
that we can have?
Say, shared economy,
or whether it
is that when you're going to
be designing your start-up,
the material that you're
using for your products
is actually having a beneficial
environmental impact?
And it's also
about understanding
where our construction
industry, which
is where 40% of our climate
carbon-related emissions
are coming from, can
actually be reduced.
So a lot of the
physical environment
that we either live
in, work in is still
going to be here in
50 years' time, right?
I mean, can you imagine
Aleppo, a 1,000-year-old city,
is still alive today.
It's been bashed about, there
have been multiple wars,
and this is just another
one to add to its history.
But it's a 1,000-year-old
city like Damascus is, right?
And so it's a really
interesting relationship
that we have with the
consequences that were almost
like Italo Calvino,
the urbanist,
would say that humans have
left a scar on the city, right?
Your relationship with
a city has remained.
It's like whatever
you did in that city
creates the legacy of that city.
And so that's sort of
some of the thoughts
that I'm sharing with you
through the presentation,
but also the things
that I get up to.
Research is really
interesting for me
because it's an
opportunity to put
a lot of the theoretical models
together with the practical,
right?
There's no point in running
a business unless you
know the theory behind it.
A lot of people go to
university to learn the theory,
but then don't know how
to put it into practice.
And that is the big challenge.
How do you put what you've
learnt, like economics,
into practice when you actually
go and leave university?
And then finally, when it
comes to the relationship
that we have with information,
it's like you can--
I can talk to you until you're
blue in the face about certain
issues, but I haven't
really learnt your form
of communication.
If you want to learn
something, there
are many ways that you learn.
But the way that you learn it
is in the context that you know,
right?
If I give you an
immersive experience,
that's going to teach you
way more than something
that you would have
to theorize before you
went into the practice of.
So a big thing for
me is, how do you
engage people into
the longer mission
with giving them these sort
of immersive experiences?
So the big question
is, considering we now
live in ecosystems and systems
and cities and economic systems
that are so interconnected,
how do we develop,
or how might we
develop an ecosystem
that replenishes planet Earth?
So what do I mean by
replenishing, right?
Replenishing is really
being carbon negative,
like the prime minister of
Bhutan talks about, Tshering
Tobgay, in his
incredible Ted talk.
He talks about this idea
that he's having a posit--
his country's having a positive
impact on the environment.
That means that you're
not zeroing out.
It's not like a zero carbon.
I've spent the carbon,
I've now sequestered it.
It's going beyond
that so that you've
got some sort of
regenerative capacity
that you're providing
planet Earth.
It means that you're
giving something
back in the form that Earth can
actually compose, like compost
it.
And that it has a
positive environment,
environmental impact.
So really, it's like
sustaining the status quo is
the way in which a lot of us,
for about a good 20 years,
have been exploring
markets and products.
It's like we're
going to match that.
We're going to sustain
the status quo.
But how can we go beyond that?
From now on, we make a pledge.
Everything that we buy
is 100% compostable.
Everything is recyclable.
Nothing goes to landfill sites.
Right?
But what's then going to happen
about the Great Pacific giant?
Who's going to clean that up?
If every country and every
citizen in the world,
everyone in the world,
decides that we're not going
to create any more waste--
but who's going to
take responsibility
for our global commons,
our urban commons,
our communal impact that is a
legacy that we've inherited.
And I think this is what
I'm trying to get to.
How can we get to a point where
we create systems naturally,
whether it's through
tech platforms
or physical platforms,
that can actually
give more than we're taking?
So I started to explore,
as I mentioned in 2015,
around about then, what
replenish actually meant.
And since then I've been
on this huge exploration.
And I realized, to bring
back that economics, right,
looking at GDP--
which is, you can spend money,
and it will look brilliant
on the accounts of a country.
Like GDP looks brilliant.
Oh, it's rising.
We're spending a lot of money.
But those expenditures--
where are they going?
And what's the impact of them?
I could be spending
money on cigarettes
that have a negative impact on
my health, which then somebody
else is going to be
paying for-- whether it's
through the National Health
Service or me, right?
It's about that I've
spent money on something--
and there's no judgment here--
but is the fact that I
spent money on something
then going to relate to a longer
term impact on expenditure,
whether it is a lung
replacement for all I care, that
is actually going to
have a negative impact
on the health of a person?
But it looks great
on GDP, because I've
spent so much money on
cigarettes or whatever else.
So there's no actual ethical
or moral or environmental
consciousness about
that expenditure.
So how do we adjust GDP to also
include, in the expenditure,
that it has a positive
impact or a negative impact
or a neutral impact?
And so I wanted to explore that
through something that's called
the World Replenish Index.
Imagine if GDP,
globally, was adjusted
by every product and service
to the environmental impact
that it had.
Would, instead of GDP, would you
have, like, a replenish count?
Just like, I'm going
to pick up your bottle,
assuming that it has a calorie
count at the back of it, which
it does.
And then all of a sudden, I'm
looking at this plastic bottle,
and I can have a
replenish count, right?
This product is level
five, let's say.
It's not there yet.
But it's at level
5 for replenish,
meaning that your diet for
replenish, like your diet would
be for something
that you consume,
was related to the
association you have
with replenishing Planet Earth.
And that's where
I want to get to.
There's a lot of information
that I need before I get there.
There's a lot of research that
I need to do before I get there.
But that's my mission.
To try and find a way that we
can develop some kind of metric
that we can measure how
people are positively
impacting Planet Earth.
And I do this
through universities.
At the moment, I've been
working with a number
of Indian universities.
I feel as if, if there's one
place that I can go to that
I could have a big impact,
I feel that it's India.
And the reason for that
is 450 million people
moving from villages,
migrating to cities, only
to find there's no
where that they can go,
and they go and live
in slums, and mostly
work in a landfill site.
And I want to stop
them from going there.
So how do I give
them the resources
that they need in a way
that, at the beginning,
they're living their
replenish lifestyle, which
is positive impact on
Planet Earth, from get go?
But how do I connect
them up in their rural,
sort of super remote areas,
and give them the resources
that they need to
be able to live
a lifestyle that is appropriate
for the environment?
A while ago you might have
heard of the One Planet Living
lifestyle, right?
And that's very
similar to the way
that I'm trying to explore this.
I took some students around
the world through a university
that I found in 2015.
And I started to explore
India's 100 smart cities.
It's this huge project
that the Indian government
has undertaken.
But with the 100
smart cities, it
doesn't mean that you've
got smart citizens.
So when the university
asked me, would you
explore what a smart city is?
I said no!
I don't want to.
I don't believe
that you can design
a smart city without
designing smart citizens.
It's like the building
is smart, but we're not.
It's like the city is
smart, but we're not.
So the emphasis is on
the technology, not us.
It's not the fact that my
consciousness has improved
and now I'm really aware of
what my building is doing.
I have no intuitive
capacity with the building.
I have no relationship
with the building.
I am a node inside the
building or the city.
I have nothing to
do with the city.
The city corrects itself.
The city manages itself.
The city is designed so that it
makes its decisions without me.
But I'm the one who's
a member of the city
and society and community
and this company, let's say.
So what do I have to give
as an individual citizen?
And how is my data being used
to then make those decisions?
And do I have ownership of that?
I mean, these are big questions
I think we can't really
answer in one session.
But one of the questions.
I really wanted to ask was
what is smart citizenship?
If you had an opportunity
to design a city,
how would you design it?
If you had an opportunity to
live in a particular place,
where would you live?
Why?
Why would you live there?
If you had an opportunity
to go further into where
your data was going to be
used, picked up, and then
analyzed and sold, shouldn't
you get a dividend on that?
And these are sort of broader
questions that I've been
asking through these courses?
But I really wanted to get
students to take them out
of their university
experience and put them
into physical spaces, where the
physical space is teaching them
the lesson that I wanted
to teach them, right,
instead of giving them
a lecture at something.
So one of the things
that I ended up doing
was taking my
students to Bhutan.
And at first they
were, like, man,
you're going to
take us to Bhutan?
And I was, like, yeah!
I'm going to take you to Bhutan.
They were, like, but
it's next to our country.
Why do we have to go there?
Why couldn't you
take us to London?
And I said, let
me take you there,
and then we'll explore
what Bhutan really is.
A And they were complaining
till we got to Bhutan.
And in the end, even though
I took them to our cities
so they can explore Masal
city, I took them to Dubai,
I brought them here.
In the end, in that
one trip, I asked them,
what was your best experience?
And they said, Bhutan was.
And I said why?
You didn't want to go there,
and now, all of a sudden
that's like one of
your favorite places.
How come?
They said, you
know, when we first
arrived there, the one
thing that we explored
was the fact that they had
such beautiful clean water.
Some of these students had never
seen such clean, natural water
in rivers.
Because a lot of
them are polluted.
Many of them had
never seen a place
that sequestered more
carbon than they made,
because they live
next door to it.
But it's just,
like, unbelievable.
They run out-- as
soon as I arrived,
we all arrived into Bhutan.
We're at Paro airport.
We're in a bus.
We're going along
to, like, Thimphu.
The bus stops for some reason.
I'm, like, snoozing off.
All the kids run off, and
I'm like, what's happened?
And I come outside, and
they're taking selfies
with the clear water.
And I'm thinking, why are you
taking a selfie with a river?
And that's the point.
It was the fact that they
had lived such clean air,
that when they go back
to Ahmedabad, which
is one of the top two
polluted cities in India,
they realize that other
things were possible, right?
I took them equally to Japan.
And in Japan, they
realize that what?
32 different types of recycling?
And you've got clear streets.
I mean, who clears them up?
Well, the community does.
The community clears
up the streets, man?
And I'm, like, yeah!
It's called [INAUDIBLE].
Every month everyone comes
out with a broomstick
and they all clean it up.
And you go to a Japanese
school, the kids come out once,
half an hour, an
hour during the day.
And they will come and
clean up the whole school.
Are they paid to do that?
I said no.
You know, they don't have
maids and someone to clean up.
I said no.
That was a joke, [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
So then I really wanted--
I sort of explored the
research angle of it.
But another thing I
really wanted to do
was to take some of these
students on a longer journey.
So I took about six different
research projects, all related
to recycling.
Because I strongly sense that
our relationship, not just with
the physical environment
affecting our brain
and changing our
chemistry, but also--
if we got them to
study the way that--
I don't know if
you've been to India.
If you have, you'll
understand and agree
with me-- is that you
walk down the street,
and you've just got piles
of rubbish everywhere.
And they're informal, and
no one cleans them up.
And if they do get
cleaned up, they're
put in an informal
landfill site.
And you look at
them and you think,
well, you know, what
kind of normal is this?
What kind of normal is this?
This is the norm.
Meaning, every time I walk
out, that's a blind spot.
That doesn't exist.
What are you talking about?
I can't see it anymore, because
that's become my normal.
And it's interesting, because
if you were to clean it up
for about 30 days,
let's say, you'd
make an imprint of a clean spot.
And now, if there
was any rubbish,
it's like, someone's
put some rubbish there.
And it's really
interesting how habits
are formed through the
visual relationship
that we have with cities.
So I wanted to explore that
with some of my students,
and I did that.
And the informal sector of
waste and how, where it goes.
There was a whole black
market of waste, which
we picked up on and documented.
But then what I wanted to do
was give them an opportunity.
And also a lot of the
people that lived in
Ahmedabad an
opportunity to explore
what it meant to be
inspired by a fellow Indian.
No, not a foreigner.
No, not someone
that you could say,
well, they went to
Harvard University.
But somebody that
could have been
a neighbor down the street.
And it was like, wow, how do I
find people that could inspire
them and that they
could explore what
it meant to be an Indian
living in today's India.
But those who were actually
challenging the same things
that they were living
through, but ignoring,
and that was a blind spot.
So I picked some
incredible people.
I don't know if
you remember, there
was a documentary recently
where the edible spoons.
You know, like
National Geographic
did like the edible spoons.
And you know, how many single
use plastics do we use?
But this guy came
along and said,
forget throwing them away.
Let's make them edible.
And so he created these
lentil-based spoons and things
that people could
actually eat with.
And so we invited him over
to be one of the speakers.
And I kind of wanted
a Ted style, you know,
inspirational 20 minutes
that you can explore.
What have I done with
some of the biggest
challenges of India?
And that was the
first talk series
that we created in January,
followed by Maker Fest.
So you know, we really want
to go into the grassroots
innovation and bring that out.
So really, one of my
inspirations from childhood
has been Sir David Attenborough.
I don't know if you
remember him from England.
You might remember his voice.
And it was the-- he's
documenting the way that people
live, Planet Earth, you know.
He'll talk about the story and
the narrative behind the way
that this animal is doing this.
And look at the way that he is.
And the reason
why he's doing it.
And it was this beautiful
narrative, Planet Earth.
But I completely get
what he's saying here.
And that is that
no one will protect
what they don't care
about, and no one
will care about what they
have never experienced.
So how do we create these
physical experiences?
Because I think an education
and experience is not just
in the head, right?
If it was, then
I'd just give you
some kind of augmented
reality or virtual reality.
And you live there.
And I'm sure you'll get
some physical repercussions
of that relationship, too.
So one of the things that we
ended up doing in Goa this year
was to question-- where
can you hide waste?
Where is it on Earth
you can put it?
Can I put it under your desk?
And the lady says no.
Can I put it in your room?
I mean, you're the
one who bought it.
You keep it.
Not my responsibility, why
are you giving it to me?
No, I'm not going
to keep it my room.
Why not?
It's yours!
See if you were to live with
your waste for one week,
in your room, in your
bedroom, like turn around,
[SPITTING NOISE],,
where would you go?
For how long could you live
with your own waste, right?
And it's interesting, because
if I were to put all of my waste
on a mountain,
right, I don't know
how big that mountain would be.
And I've started to
realize, oh, my god.
Where is that going?
So where are we
hiding our waste?
And so that is a question.
We then put a whole
installation together.
And the Indian government
was really impressed with it.
They asked us, can we make
it permanent installation?
So they gave us a
shipping container,
and then we painted
it all black.
We put these
incredible UV sort of--
using blacklight sort
of paints in there,
and then we took
them on a minijourney
around this installation.
And the point of it was
what is a seahorse doing
holding a straw?
It's, like, why are there
plastics in the ocean?
Who does the sea belong to?
And then as you go
through, there's
like a very kiddie friendly and
adult friendly sort of dialogue
that we create with
people as they're
going through the installation.
Got to a point at
the back where they
had all these
beautiful jellyfish,
and they're just
jellyfish, right?
And you're looking at the
back, and you're, like, wow,
the kids are like
they're jellyfish!
Are you sure they're jellyfish?
Yes!
They're jellyfish.
And then I'm, like, wrong.
And like you, this
turtle has no idea
that that is not a jellyfish.
It's a plastic bag.
And so it is really
this opportunity
that I had to
question the plastics,
but through the lifestyles
that we're living.
And I think just on
the right-hand side
of this picture, you'll
get to see the shrine
that I put together for all of
the different kinds of plastics
that anyone could have had.
So then turned to them and said,
oh, is this your plastic bag?
I don't know!
Could it be?
Could it be mine?
You know, is that your straw?
And then to sort of explore
this dialogue of plastics
and plastic diet, it's
like a plastic footprint.
And then the other
thing that I really
want to explore through this
installation was microplastics.
We talk about plastics
being in the ecosystem.
But are we consuming
that plastic, too?
And there is research in
so many different countries
now, India as well--
AUDIENCE: There's
a documentary that
says that scientists
couldn't find a single water
sample from the entire world
that doesn't have microplastics
in it.
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: That's
shocking and scares me.
So what he said was that
scientists cannot find a single
sample of water around the
world that doesn't have plastic
inside it.
Now what's really interesting,
and most of our water bodies
are completely connected,
in most of our water bodies,
a lot of that plastic
comes together.
And that's why we
got these big, like,
Ellen MacArthur has
traveled around the world
and found out that there's
huge garbage patches which
are the size of countries.
Like, there's one the size
of France floating about.
And there's no sun
that goes through
to photosynthesize the algae.
But what's really
fascinating for me
is that microplastics
that break down are
found in the underwater.
But they're also
found in the animals.
And they're also found in us.
And what's that stage where the
plastic that we're putting out
in the world comes back and
hits us into our stomachs?
I wonder if there
is a way that now we
can actually start analyzing
how many plastics exist in us.
There's a bit of a
grim story, I suppose,
and "The Times of
India" picked up on it
and said that there
are some things
that we should be
able to communicate
through an installation.
The Hindostan waste plant
has put that installation
on their ground.
So if any of you are
ever going to Goa,
you are welcome to
go and visit it.
But the point of the
insulation wasn't-- oh, my god,
plastics are taking
over the world.
It was what are the three
things that you can do, now
that you walk out of
here, that can have
a huge impact on Planet Earth?
One of them, say
no to plastic bags,
like single use plastic
bags or straws, right?
Get your own straw.
And just like when you're
about to order your food--
and I've got preferences, I
don't like onions, let's say--
then you tell people, don't you?
You say, order that pizza
without onions, please.
In the same way, order my
drink without a plastic straw.
And now that I've
started doing that,
I remember there was
a cafe down the street
from the installation.
People will at me and say,
you don't want a straw?
I said, you know what?
Do me a favor.
Don't give anyone
this week a straw.
But keep them there.
Keep the straws there,
but don't give it to them.
If they ask for it, they
know where to find it.
So that's one step that
you could take that reduces
the amount of plastic.
But also, instead of having
multiple plastic bottles
for water, how about if you had
one refillable water bottle,
right, and one of
those big containers
that you can actually
just refill instead
of having plastic bottles.
And every single day, I don't
know how many of these plastic
bottles we seem to be consuming.
So the point of it
wasn't how awful
are we-- guilt tripping them.
But actually getting them
to a point of saying, well,
what can I do, now that I
can tangibly take that away.
So now I'm moving into this
whole idea of dialogue.
A lot of the communication
that we've been given
is, I find, traumatizing.
Makes me feel awful.
I just want to like climb
underneath a blanket and cry.
But what to do to have
this conversation?
How did we get there?
This is, like, imagine if every
single person on Planet Earth
could have a
replenish lifestyle,
could actually benefit
Planet Earth in some way.
It's a dual thing.
Number one is how do
we have that dialogue.
I don't know if any of
you have been recipients
of trolling on online.
But I have.
And it feels horrible, you know?
It's, like, why
are you doing this?
And you've never met me.
And you've got an opinion
on who I am as a person.
But that kind of dialogue
and the relationship
that we have with one another,
I think, is really important.
Because imagine if, like,
we're sitting at dinner,
and three of you have
got your phones out.
And your mom's sitting
there, and saying, well,
put your phones away.
Was there a
conversation we should
have had at the beginning
to then get to a point
where, at dinner, agreed--
negotiations over here.
We're compromising
on this table.
We're not going to
have phones, fine.
Cool.
Do it before, do it after,
but not at the dinner table.
Now that you've had
this conversation, that
is the foundation, the
process that you're
going to use for
that dialogue that
is important for a lot
of the technology that
is coming into our lives.
So in the same
way, a lot of 4.0,
so many different
kinds of technologies
are actually on market.
But is there a
point where we need
to learn how to best
dialogue with each other
to form some social parameters,
some kind of conversations,
nonviolent communication,
that can actually
get us on par with where
we need to go next?
And how do we have
that conversation?
So I'd like to say, at the
beginning of this year,
I came together with DX
Labs, based in San Francisco.
They work with
Singularity as well.
And one of the things
that I really wanted to do
was write an article, a
story, about what would happen
if you lived with a neuro link.
If you, let's say, were
completely online with a brain.
I mean a lot of
that technology has
come into some sort of
research laboratories.
And I kind of
imagine what it would
feel like to have a
brain machine interface.
But instead of getting to the
point where having opinions--
for some reason, stories,
like, really cool stories,
like, sci-fi stories
and videos and movies,
can allow us to ask those
questions in a safe space.
So I started to write.
And on Medium, I
wrote this post,
"Replenish, the Convergence
of AI and Ecology."
And there's two parts.
And I'd love to know what
you thought about it.
But what was, for
me, really intriguing
is that there
comes a point where
technology and nature merge.
Imagine-- you know,
you might know
Meow-Meow, who's got a
biometric scanner in his arm.
And then he sort of
uploads the data.
So we're coming to that
point of quantified self.
I've got a Fitbit on me.
We're getting to that point
where we're merging with tech.
And at that point,
at what point, yeah--
where do we become
the technology
that we're also
introducing into our lives?
And it's a really
interesting question for me.
Because imagine if
the whole of our brain
was uploaded onto the internet,
and that brain could then
be analyzed and your
thoughts analyzed
and whatever kind of
interesting behaviors we had
could, in some way, even be
controlled or manipulated?
But if we had an opportunity to
actually enhance that and put
that forward, and we could
have a dialogue about it,
where would that dialogue go?
But also about this sort
of-- the automation,
I think, of life, the automation
of a lot of the challenges
that we've got.
Where do we get to a point
where that automation becomes
with or without the direction
that we're giving it?
Here's some of the research
that we did on the whole brain.
But also, where would
we put that technology,
and having
conversations about it.
And it's been really interesting
to explore this technology
through the lens of an
individual who would say,
I would never have
something like that done.
But to explore it through
a story is much easier.
And so to have that
conversation, even though it's
not real, is almost
easier for people
to sort of interact with.
So we talked about Industry
4.0 entering the market.
But also, when it comes to the
sustainable development goals
that the United
Nations have launched,
was how much is
this industry worth?
Should we really
bother about it?
And the WEF has actually put
a sum, $2.5 trillion on it.
I think the next step
is really to understand
where we can go with that.
If you had $2.5 trillion
of a budget towards this,
where would we
direct our research?
What kind of businesses
would we create?
What kind of cities
would we design?
So some of the work that I've
been doing here has been in--
I mentioned the Gulf
benchmark on energy.
What that then led
to was an article,
I think in "The Gulf"
or "The National"
that was too cold for comfort.
I feel physical buildings
being way too cold,
and people are
getting ill from them.
And that was with the
National Bank of Abu Dhabi.
Some of the work that
I've done, and trying
to explore whether it should
be a top down or a bottom up
approach.
Where are these smart
cities taking us?
And where do we have an
opportunity to be part of that?
There was a project that I
did with the Premier of South
Australia, Jay
Weatherill, and it
was really about understanding
what does carbon negative mean,
or carbon neutral
mean, and where can we
push the boundaries of that?
So it's interesting,
because whoever we are,
are based on the
experiences that we've had.
But when we start to combine
our knowledge and experiences,
we almost actualize a
community of knowledge,
like a collaboration.
But it's going beyond that
that's really interesting
to understand.
How do we get to a point
where we can really
explore all of our learnings
together through this,
and with that, our fears?
And this really goes back to
a very interesting project
in the UK, which a
friend of mine has got.
His name is Simon Gosling.
And he's exploring
what smart means.
So he brings people
into this future home
and explores the dialogues
that he's having with them.
So if you're ever in London, I'd
love to introduce you to him.
And this is a very
small project that I've
got with about 300
villages surrounding
Surat which is one of
the fastest growing
cities in India.
But as you can see, one of
the big projects of India
is [INAUDIBLE],, which is about
that kind of ideal village,
and exploring what that means,
even though you walk down
the street, and you've got these
piles and piles of rubbish.
So how do we take this
whole replenish philosophy
and plug it into
the rural sector
and actually help
people to transition
to that kind of a lifestyle?
Another thing that
I did recently
was in Brazil,
where we celebrated
a whole week of zero waste.
And one of the most
exciting things that I saw
was an actual
supermarket that is 96%--
and it's a massive supermarket--
[INAUDIBLE] market
that is 96% zero waste.
And you know, we developed and
designed some ideas for Lisbon
being a zero waste city.
But I think we're
almost at that point
where a lot of cities
and a lot of companies
are actually taking on
much more practical levels
of appreciating and translating
this kind of philosophy.
So you can find out more
about me on our newsletter.
I normally kind of post
any new bits or new pieces
of information that I collect.
The next steps for me really
are consolidating about 10
years' worth of travel and
understanding what is next.
Like, if we were to introduce
this whole economic paradigm,
like, the World Replenish
Index, and you had,
at the back of your bottles, and
everything that you consumed,
a Replenish indicator, would
you live a replenish diet?
And how much of that
would be your lifestyle?
You know how-- let's
say I'm vegan, right?
But I'm vegan in my
diet, not my lifestyle.
How would I translate the
vegan to the lifestyle as well?
How do I translate
this lifestyle
into something that is
appropriate for Planet Earth?
So I'm exploring these things.
I was really grateful
to have shared
some of my work with
you, but also some
of the challenges and the
questions that are leading me
and the vision that
I've got for it.
I really hope that in
maybe 10 to 20 years' time,
we can look back and say that
the planet that we live on
is an ecosystem
that we're part of.
But it's an ecosystem
that we're together
with, that we can work together
on creating a replenish earth,
replenishing lifestyle from.
And I think there's these
ideas almost of, like,
moving away from the
challenges of living
in a lifestyle like this.
And maybe it's going backwards.
You know, going to live
in a village in India
is not necessarily
the challenge.
But exploring those
things in the cities
and the buildings and the
companies that we live
and work in.
So thank you very
much for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
- The floor is yours.
Any questions, please?
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you for coming.
Very inspiring story and
projects you're working on.
TIA KANSARA HON
FRIBA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
is around this.
I find this is a
fascinating new challenge.
Because from one side,
our actions as individuals
can individually impact
negatively Planet Earth.
But we don't reap the benefit
unless we act collectively,
either at the local level or
at the country level, or even
at the Earth level.
Which makes our action
remote, or the impact
remote from the action
that we do as individuals.
And breaking this vicious
cycle of us doing good actions
and seeing the benefit
is very critical.
Now there are a lot
of government actions,
from a regulation point of
view which have been around,
effective or not, subject
to politics and economics,
and technology clearly has
some efficiency promise
for companies.
But I love what you
mentioned about bringing it
to an individual
level, and having
the index on every bottle
or on every product.
So my question for
you is that when
we see a calorie or
an organic label,
we link that to ourselves or
our individual [INAUDIBLE]..
But when we see a
replenish label,
we cannot relate it to
our individual well-being,
unless everyone
else sign up for it.
How do you think are the most
interesting ideas and the most
effective ones in relating more
of this index or similar labels
to individual well-being,
being tangible or nontangible?
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: That's
such an interesting way
of seeing it.
And I'm really grateful that you
brought this to our attention.
Because I think that
individual, almost
like a per capita income-- who
cares about per capita income,
apart from the fact that I'm
part of this economy, right?
Per capita income's got nothing
to do with me personally.
It's what the
government is actually
assigning to the
well-being, financially,
of this member who
lives in this country.
So this is a very
interesting concept,
because now it identifies who
I am as an individual, right?
The fact that I'm a
vegan has got nothing
to do with anybody else unless
if I'm going to go and tell
everybody that they should
stop eating meat because it
has a negative impact
on the environment.
But I could have a lifestyle
that is completely wrong.
And that's really
interesting, because now,
with data, just like you would
do with your smartphone data
and what you're consuming
on an individual level,
imagine if that data backed
up who you were as a person.
China's introducing already
this social indexing, right?
Imagine if each
person had some kind
of even account that
could bring them credit
for doing certain things.
And if maybe that
turned into money,
like a monetary taxation, right,
that you didn't have to pay.
Because hey, you don't
need to collect my rubbish.
I don't have any.
So now it turns this whole
idea of civic, right,
this whole community communal.
If, let's say, in
China, for example,
that the hospital that is all
about preventative health,
right--
it's not about how many
chemicals and medicines can
I have now that I've got ill.
But it's how do I stop you from
getting ill in the first place?
I think that's the
kind of approach
that we need to take
for Planet Earth,
how do we stop her getting
ill in the first place?
And how in on an
individual scale,
can we incentivize
individuals that we are
part of that global ecosystem?
This is the biggest challenge.
Because if you can crack
that, you've cracked it all.
Because on that
individual level,
you need to know how
much you've done.
I'm selfish.
You know?
If I spent more
money on creating,
maybe a LEED platinum
building, or whatever
rating system, Pearl 5, I want
to get some benefit from that.
And that might be
an ego thing, right,
but it depends on
the consciousness
of the individual.
Perhaps I don't need you to
tell me that I've done well.
So it depends on the
person and the community
at the time of how that
incentivization scheme could
work.
But I could totally see that
some kind of economic benefits,
tariffs, quotas that
you could meet that
could actually reduce, not just
the global sort of parameters,
but a local parameter.
Imagine that, in the UK,
we've got the Bristol pound.
We've got currency
in a certain locale.
Now that I've got the--
the Bristol pound and the
British pound are equal.
They are equally
used in Bristol.
But the fact that I've
now got a local currency
means that my currency remains
within Bristol, because it
can't be used in London.
So it's like a localization
of a global issue.
I don't know if that really
answered your question.
I wasn't meaning to
answer the question,
but add a few more
thoughts to it.
Because I don't think
anyone's got the answer.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: Yes?
AUDIENCE: There's a question.
Are you [INAUDIBLE]?
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA:
I am not at the moment.
I'm trying.
So for example,
I don't eat meat.
I don't eat fish.
That's one thing that
I'm trying to do.
The second thing is, I
don't buy anything anymore.
I borrow things instead.
So instead of
buying more things,
like, if you go into my home,
I've got all these books.
I don't know what
to do with them.
And so what I'm doing is
giving those books away.
Trying to understand, like, OK,
if I want to acquire knowledge,
how best do I do that?
So I'm picking different
aspects of my lifestyle
and exploring what I can do.
So for example,
with replenishing,
I'm finding ways
that I can sequester.
Where can I, perhaps,
not have a straw?
So through my
behavior, I'm trying
to figure out how I can live
a much more negative, carbon
negative lifestyle?
But also, what are the metrics?
Like, if you look at some of the
carbon sequestration metrics,
it's like, oh, if we
plant another five trees,
we're going to get there.
No, we're not, because five
trees that you've taken down
are full fledglings.
They're completely grown and
their sequestering capacity
is not the same as a sapling.
And these are some of
the kind of questions
that I'm asking not only
myself, but exploring
through new products
that are on the market.
And exploring, hey, these
are the alternatives.
So through my own learnings,
I'm posting a lot of that
through a Facebook group.
So that when I'm learning
something, I'm like, wow,
that's really cool.
I don't expect to be carbon
neutral or negative today.
I expect to be
there, transitioning
to it, with a mindful
step by step process.
It's, like, from now, from
one step to the other,
you're probably not going
to become a nonsmoker.
But you're probably
going to take measures
to sort of reduce the amount
of impact of certain chemicals
that you might have.
Or you might go towards a
natural tobacco, let's say.
That there are
different measures
that you can take for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Question for [INAUDIBLE].
I think your cause is probably
one of the noblest answers
to the why of [INAUDIBLE].
So thanks for sharing.
TIA KANSARA HON
FRIBA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Elon Musk and his
work-- he does two things,
and I think they're
complete things.
One is trying to make
life on the planet better,
with solar power and
solar powered cars.
And on the other end, trying
to start a colony on Mars
as sort of a safety net for
in case Plan A didn't work.
What do you think
of that safety net?
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: I
find it really interesting.
So he was in Adelaide at the
same time that I was there.
But he was promoting
this whole--
because we had a huge
blackout in South Australia.
And because of that, through
a little Twitter sort
of understanding, there
was this huge project
that came about in [INAUDIBLE].
And I think that these--
I'm going to call them hairy,
ambitious goals, right?
Going carbon negative or neutral
is a hairy, ambitious goal.
And we've got to all plug in
different bits of knowledge
and information
to understand what
the whole elephant looks like.
It's, like, I'm
blind, but I can feel
the eyelashes of the elephant.
So it's coming
together and knowing
that is what the
elephant is, that's one.
On his mission to Mars,
I think, you know--
I can take it.
Like, are you
trying to run away?
You know, like--
you know that movie?
What's the name of that
movie with that robot
that lives on Planet Earth,
and he's, like, packaging up
the waste and putting--
AUDIENCE: "WallE."
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: "WallE!"
Imagine it's like "WallE"
where, in 50 years' time,
we're getting to a point
where we are living
the "WallE" lifestyle, getting
fat on some sort of hovering
device.
And just light pinging each
other on whatever Facebook
device we're going to be using.
And I think we could
either take it that way,
or we could look at
it as a hairy goal.
Are we going to get
somewhere, if we
were to redirect our
attention to something that we
could actually do?
And if we could actually
do that, what then can
we actually do here?
And I think there is, maybe, a
small number of crazy people.
I think he's one of them.
But crazy in a good way.
It's like saying that is
a challenge that I don't
think we can do, or can we?
And I think more than anything
I take that as a learning.
That my god-- if you can get
to Mars, what can't we do here?
And perhaps this
whole Mars mission
is, like, I'm going to
put some money towards it
because I can
afford it, he says.
But it's not to do that.
It's to bring our
attention to the fact
that if we were to spend
time and money on making
Earth better, we probably
wouldn't want to go there.
Or maybe we'd want
to go and explore it.
Just like going to
the moon was, like,
we're going to go to the moon.
In 10 years' time, we
want to get to the moon.
It was the fact that
we had 10 years' time.
It was a confined time period.
It was a huge task.
And that many people had to
come together to achieve that.
It's like Steve
Jobs, 10 years ago,
brings out this platform
called the iPhone.
No one's ever heard of
a smartphone before.
It's, like, what?
But he didn't do it alone.
He created something that
came from an ecosystem of all
of his military and
academic research that
had gone into making
the iPhone possible.
I think this is where
someone like Elon Musk is.
Who, like me, travels
around the world
and doesn't really have a home,
because Planet Earth is home.
And it's, like, how do you
create some kind of association
to these kinds of
challenges that we globally
need to be aware of?
And I remember
this conversation.
I've kind of taking
a bit of a tangent,
but I hope you'll appreciate it.
I sat next to this
girl in London.
We're having a cup of tea.
And she says, Tia,
I don't really
care what happens in China.
What sustainability?
And I said, you don't care
about what happens in China.
I want you to go home,
turn everything around,
have a look at the "Made In",
and tell me what percentage
of your things come from where.
She said, I did that--
60%.
I said, do you, or
do you not have,
even if it's just economic,
do you or do you not have
a relationship with China then?
Does your demand
for these things,
whether you like it or not,
and there are no alternatives,
perhaps, have something to do
with what happens in China?
And I think this is what it is.
How can we make it
visible, but not
make people feel guilty from it.
And that's the challenge.
How do we positively reinforce,
with alternatives and fun
innovations and cool
ways of doing it?
And I think maybe
he's a bit bonkers.
Who am I to judge?
AUDIENCE: So on
that note, I don't
know if you agree
but humans are, like,
a selfish species where--
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA:
Oh, "The Selfish Gene,"
by Richard Dawkins.
Here we go.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] we're
prone to be addicted to things.
And we're addicted
to feeling good.
And if it makes me
feel good to throw away
a piece of plastic
spoon and I don't
have to wash it after every time
I eat, how are you going to--
once people have tasted that
feeling of goodness, right,
how are you going to
get them away from it?
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: OK.
AUDIENCE: Especially
if they might
argue that I'm not
really, in my lifetime,
going to see the consequences
of what I'm doing?
That's the greedy part.
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: I can
say one thing, definitely.
Who seeded that
idea in your head?
AUDIENCE: Personal experience.
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: Could
be personal experience,
but it could be anyone, right?
At any stage,
somebody in society,
or through subconscious
messaging has got us,
me included, to believe
something that is the case.
There is no status quo.
Therefore, everything
can be questioned.
The way that we live--
I learned this when
I was in Japan.
I remember coming from
England, 22 years old,
just finished my
university degree.
Arrived in Japan, and
they say, this is wrong.
In England, OK, I'm
taking one example.
In England, when you're
sitting next to somebody
that you don't know
at the bus stop,
you start talking
about the weather.
But you'd normally
talk about how shit is.
You're like, oh, the weather
is really bad, isn't it?
And somebody turns around
and is, like, yeah, god,
it's been raining all day.
That could be good as well.
The weather's really good today.
Oh, oh, it's lovely.
But it's an excuse to
have a chat with somebody.
Well, I went to
Japan, and I started
to use the negative to open up
dialogue, and it didn't work.
I'm not being negative.
It's just some--
and then I realized.
The way that I do
things isn't necessarily
right in another culture or
another place in the world,
in other conversation.
It doesn't.
Just because one way is right,
doesn't mean another way
is wrong, too.
And I think that's a very
interesting psychological,
waiting or anchoring that
we've all been exposed to.
If you go back to, I think
it was the 1950s and '60s,
Edward Bernays was one of
the most incredible PR agents
at the time.
What he did, Marlborough,
smoking company, went to him
and said, we don't
have any women smokers.
What do we do about it?
He went and did some research.
He found out that women felt
a certain way about smoking
and putting this
stick into the mouth
was something that
they didn't want to do.
So then he explored how the
relationship and the sort
of branding behind it--
but explored what
does it mean for them.
Explored the meaning and how
he could shift that meaning
and made an
incredible difference.
He hired 10 beautiful
women, the beginning
of the march for female freedom,
gave them all cigarettes,
lit them up, called the
press, took some photographs,
and boom!
Did that one event have a
huge impact on the sales
that females were
smoking cigarettes for?
It's really interesting for me.
But the way that
we influence people
and the psychological
messaging that we give them,
whether it's commercials,
whether it's data
that we analyze and show--
I think a lot of
that intention has
been set by someone
or something,
mostly for reasons of
their own causes, right?
I'm going to try and
sell you a Coca-Cola
can no matter what
I can do, even
if I'm stepping on a
Pepsi can in an advert.
But I know, and
you know, that it's
got like huge amounts of
sugar and a chemical that
stops my mouth exploring
that there is too much sugar
in my mouth.
Is that fair or not fair?
Well, it's FDA approved.
OK, fine.
So it's really interesting how
a lot of that research now, all
of our experimentation
has allowed to us
may be becoming more conscious
about certain things, and not.
And I don't think
anything is written.
I think we have an opportunity
to explore everything.
Like a teacher that I used
to have in one of my classes
when I was younger.
She used to say, well, that's
just the way that it is.
And I'm saying, well,
I don't think so.
Well, something inside me
tells me it's not that way.
But she would often say, well,
that's just the way that it is.
So it's interesting.
If you were to explore another
way of being, another language,
another narrative,
another identity,
and you had no holds
barred, who would you be?
You can be anyone.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
the last question.
We are running out of time.
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA:
Where did the time go?
AUDIENCE: I was very
interested in the index
you were talking about.
And I was wondering if, when
you took to, I don't know,
[INAUDIBLE] or
even annually could
help implement this index.
Is there a company
in the world that
is interested in doing this?
Is it something that looks
completely idealistic
and is never going to happen?
And [INAUDIBLE] to happen.
[INAUDIBLE] So what's
the state of this?
TIA KANSARA HON FRIBA: It's
a really good question.
So Bhutan, this year,
launched the GNH business.
Bhutan introduced the
Gross National Happiness
index in the 1970s.
And wanted to understand what if
the economy wasn't about money,
but it was about well-being?.
And so they started to
explore this whole well-being.
And I think it was 1970s onwards
is when, every three years, all
of this data was
collected to show
what was the state of
well-being in their country.
And then what they did was to
explore a happiness report.
And I think you may be aware
that many other countries
around the world
have been looking
at well-being, British
government being one of them.
The UAE has been talking
about well-being as well,
happiness ministers,
very interesting sort
of understanding and
appreciation of well-being.
Another thing that they've
recently launched last year,
a couple of years ago they did
the Gross National Happiness,
seventh conference.
Or sixth conference-- this
year it was the seventh.
And they said, what if
businesses were also
aligned with this?
And they said, OK,
well, you're going
to be introducing this to
businesses already and probably
taking a top down approach.
They took 40
different businesses
and asked them whether they were
approaching their businesses
with the kind of well-being
index within the context
of the products and services
and the employees that
work there, kind of, like,
the organizational structure.
And when this came
out, one of the things
that I suggested to the
Bhutanese [INAUDIBLE]
but also their team at the
center of Bhutanese studies
was you're doing the well-being.
Why don't you also do the
environmental side of it, too?
So if you were to, like B corps,
analyze the whole business
and the impact that it had
on the environment as well
as the well-being, what kind
of a metric would you have?
You'd be the first in
the world to do it.
So we're exploring
that together.
It's funny, actually.
You know, at the
beginning of the year
when I was writing
the convergence of AI
and ecology piece, I watched all
of the "Black Mirror" series.
I don't know if you've
come across that.
It was so much fun.
I loved it.
And one of the things
that I came across
was, if I could write
a piece for the future,
like 40 years, maybe even 30 or
10 years, of how this could be.
I went a bit crazy
and I wrote that.
It then became the preliminary
piece for the "Medium" article.
But one of the things that I
wrote was, in two years' time--
and I wrote it as if
I was looking back.
So two years ago, this
suggestion was made.
And then this was implemented at
the government level in Bhutan.
And it's interesting how
that is happening now.
And I wonder if because
that intention was there,
that something like this
has actually manifested.
I have a very interesting
relationship with intuition
and manifestation.
But many different
countries around the world
from a government level are
trying to introduce this.
Like in Goa, with the
installation they suggested--
2019-- what about if we had
a festival on zero waste?
Funny, because the festival that
we had this art installation
for a year ago, I suggested, how
about if we have our festival,
a zero waste festival?
And they said, well, why
don't you do it first,
and then we'll see how, from
the evaluation, we could do it.
And it's funny that the
government is now suggesting--
completely unrelated,
the government
is suggesting we have
like zero waste festival.
But I think there
are pockets of people
coming together and doing
very interesting things.
But for the World
Replenish Index
at MIT last year in
December, I launched
something called the
Replenish Business Canvas.
And I wanted to suggest that,
if every single startup, not
[INAUDIBLE] company,
come to the end of it,
and now I've got
some money, I'll put
some money towards [INAUDIBLE].
Uh huh.
Right at the
beginning, when you're
formulating your
company, you could
say that this company is going
to be a zero waste company.
And where am I going
to get materials from?
So right at inception, you could
introduce this whole idea--
what kind of businesses
would we have in the future?
And I'm surprised, but
even at Harvard and MIT,
both of their MBA programs, as
well as Oxford Said business
school, do not have
enough case studies
of businesses that have done
extremely well in this field.
So that's one of the projects
within the World Replenish
Index, to build on the case
studies of business model
innovation of where businesses
have done it, have made it.
So it's a lot of work.
And I need a lot of help.
Maybe some of you will help me.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]